y is directly proportional to x.
If y equals 30 when
x is equal to 6,
find the value of
x when y is 45.
So let's just take this
each statement at a time.
y is directly proportional to x.
That's literally
just saying that y
is equal to some
constant times x.
This statement can
literally be translated
to y is equal to some
constant times x.
y is directly proportional to x.
Now, they tell us, if
y is 30 when x is 6--
and we have this constant
of proportionality--
this second statement
right over here
allows us to solve
for this constant.
When x is 6, they
tell us y is 30
so we can figure out
what this constant is.
We can divide both
sides by 6 and we
get this left-hand side is
5-- 30 divided by 6 is 5.
5 is equal to k or
k is equal to 5.
So the second sentence tells us,
this gives us the information
that y is not just k
times x, it tells us
that y is equal to 5 times
x. y is 30 when x is 6.
And then finally, they say, find
the value of x when y is 45.
So when y is 45 is
equal to-- so we're just
putting in 45 for y--
45 is equal to 5x.
Divide both sides
by 5 to solve for x.
We get 45 over 5 is 9, and
5x divided by 5 is just x.
So x is equal to 9 when y is 45.